black owned businesses are popping up
all around the country they sure are the
census shows entrepreneurship in the
black community has seen the largest
growth for any group since before the
pandemic but many of those businesses
are considered micro businesses Kenneth
Charles joins us live in The Newsroom
with all of those details Candace good
morning to good morning folks The
Brookings institution reports that only
two percent of black businesses
Nationwide are owners of employers firms
which are businesses that employ people
the co-chair of small business for
America's future tells me that here in
Nevada there are more than 26 000 black
owned firms and 25 000 have no employees
at all making them micro businesses the
reason Capital employer firms are bigger
and require more Capital than many black
small business owners have access to
unfortunately due to racial disparities
and who gets loans recently the
infrastructure Bill tried to correct
this by making the minority business
development agency or mbda a permanent
destination to fill those gaps and bring
Capital black owned and minority
businesses but having a successful
business is about more than money
you can really own a business and start
a business it takes it takes passion it
takes Ingenuity it takes uh
determination it takes resiliency those
are all the things you do anyway if you
want to keep a job so you the only other
part that you have to do is you have to
fund your own dream
sorry uh some new there is the owner of
some new marketing and the co-chair of
small business for America's future he
says what else is needed for more black
businesses to get started and for more
of those micro businesses to grow and
stay open is technical assistance so
people can understand how to run a
business and know where to go when they
get in trouble and there are resources
folks including the urban Chamber of
Commerce and the Nevada entrepreneur
Network and more we have details on our
website on 8newsnow.com